[Música]
en primera plana
braulio moro
[Música]
bienvenidos a en primera plana una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español dedicada al análisis de la
actualidad internacional este 8 de marzo
se celebra la jornada internacional de
los derechos de las mujeres aquí en
francia la violencia contra el sexo
femenino y los feminicidios están
causando bastante polémica que se puede
esperar a menos de 30 días de las
elecciones presidenciales en francia
para hablar de ello saludamos ya a
nuestras invitadas de nuestros estudios
tenemos a maría eugenia uriburu
psicóloga bienvenida muchas gracias
en concepto de té con nosotros a maría
josé zorrilla politóloga muy buenos días
y paula martínez periodista
independiente también gracias por la
invitación
cuál es la situación de los derechos de
las mujeres a menos de 30 días de las
elecciones presidenciales que balance de
la presidencia macro estamos aquí en
primera plana
[Música]
vamos a ver lo que dicen precisamente
algunas de las portadas de los diarios
franceses sobre el tema de la violencia
contra las mujeres comenzamos con el
tabloide le télégramme el telegrama que
plantea precisamente en portada presenta
las fotografías de nueve mujeres y dice
sencillamente
feminicidio tras las palabras las vidas
robadas otro tabloide perdón el sudoeste
escribe con grandes titulares justicia
que medidas para llevar justicia a este
tipo de crímenes y finalmente el
periódico liberación que su portada con
grandes letras rojas y negras escribe
femenicidios el fracaso
maría eugenia yo quisiera preguntarle el
primero cuál es la diferencia entre
feminicidio y violencia contra las
mujeres
bueno él el feminicidio es una muerte
violenta hacia las mujeres o las niñas
de manera no natural
muerte violenta es decir
puede ser por accidente por
homicidio o suicidio
hostigado exactamente o por las muertes
dudosas pero bueno la definición es
bastante ahora les voy a dar un poquito
más de detalles pero la diferencia con
la violencia hacia las mujeres es que
las violencias son más
bueno de diferentes tipos tenemos la
violencia psicológica la violencia
económica violencia sexual la violencia
económica pero no tenemos es
necesariamente la muerte por supuesto la
violencia física también pero no está
el aspecto mortal de la muerte violenta
en todos los casos en matices de
consideración sí muy importante y además
este término da visibilidad a bueno
digamos las convenciones internacionales
han utilizado este término de
convenciones internacionales de lucha
contra la violencia hacia las mujeres
porque da la visibilidad al aspecto del
género que es respecto digamos un
asesinato porque son mujeres porque son
mujeres o identificadas con el sexo
femenino y
bueno como decía las convenciones
internacionales que describen los
feminicidios no solamente en la
violencia doméstica es decir en la
pareja esto entraría dentro de la
categoría de los interpersonales pero
definen también como
en el sentido político cultural criminal
sexual
político por las persecuciones o los
abortos forzados
y cultural los crímenes de honor
criminal sexuales en el tráfico y la
trata de mujeres entonces tenemos ya un
cuadro general precisamente que permite
diferenciar una y otra situación maria
jose yo quisiera preguntarle por qué el
feminicidio se volvió un tema de
actualidad pero no es un tema central en
la campaña presidencial que decíamos
estamos a menos de 30 días precisamente
de las elecciones en francia porque esta
problemática como lo ven ustedes claro
bueno lo que sucede es que el
feminicidio de la cuestión menos
importante para los candidatos de las
cuestiones más importantes o sea a
diferencia de la migración de justamente
ahora la crisis en ucrania el pase más
thaksin al las medidas por el cob y el
feminicidio no es una cuestión que
genere polémica o que genere justamente
división entre la masa electoral por lo
tanto no trabaja no trae votos por algún
consenso si podríamos decir que hay un
consenso y como estamos en un momento de
la campaña una fase de la campaña
presidencial
determinante en donde cada candidato
sobre todo los de derechas van a
intentar como y diferenciarse entre
ellos y resaltar individuos individuos o
analizar se va a ser muy complicado y
justamente a partir de la segunda vuelta
es donde normalmente los candidatos van
a intentar tender puentes entre ellos y
justamente puede llegar a ser una
oportunidad para los movimientos
feministas para las movilizaciones
feministas y estos sectores para
justamente buscar consensos con estos
partidos políticos de acuerdo quiero
citar una cuestión cuando porque las
declaraciones finalmente pesan en 2018
cuando el presidente de manuel macrón
acababa de ganar la presidencia hizo una
declaración que me parece interesante
recordar él prometió que la lucha contra
la violencia hacia las mujeres sería los
citó la gran causa del que ingenio cinco
años después nos encontramos con una
situación que vale la pena también
señalar cada año desde el 2018 hasta
ahora ha habido más de 100 mujeres
asesinadas en francia en este sentido
paola martínez es un balance un poco por
lo menos por lo que se puede ser por lo
menos poco favorable para el presidente
mal balance diría yo ya el hecho que
haya una sola mujer asesinada por el
hecho de ser mujer es un balance para el
gobierno si bien es cierto el manuel
macro decidió como bien lo decía de
hacer el pilar de su de su mandato la
lucha contra las violencias y erradicar
erradicar apuntó en esa palabra fuerte
léelo feminicidio cuando hoy día estamos
a 4 de marzo y hay 15 feminicidios en
francia el año pasado hubo 113 mujeres
que murieron eso da cuenta de la
gravedad del problema es cierto que los
candidatos no tienen en su primera
prioridad el servicio pero hay que
tratarlo como una prioridad el que
inicio es la punta de la expert de las
violencias familiares de las violencias
conyugales que existen en este país
porque porque una sociedad profundamente
patriarcal donde el sistema disfuncional
en la cual las mujeres que van a
denunciar los casos de violencia no son
escuchadas son humilladas recientemente
hubo un caso fuertísimo que chocó la
opinión pública donde un policía trata
una mujer que fue a denunciar disputa
después de que anunció su violación
entonces cuando tenemos casos así en una
sociedad entre comillas libre liberada
como la francesa en la cual la libertad
y los derechos fundamentales y tenemos
una parte una traje de estado que no
acompaña a esas mujeres para poder
llevar a cabo sus denuncias y ser
acompañadas principalmente por eso el
balance de los cinco años que han pasado
casi del mandato de magna macro ni yo
considero que es un un mal balance
porque no debiera haber hoy día ninguna
mujer asesinada por el hecho de ser
mujer tenemos algunas cifras que me
parece que es importante en 2018 hubo
120 mujeres asesinadas en 2019
156 en el 2020 102 2021 113 y en lo que
va de este año llevamos ya 11 mujeres
asesinadas marc y eugenia que lectura se
puede hacer de estas cifras
bueno son cifras estables desde hace
muchos años
estos son
estos datos del estudio nacional sobre
las mujeres sobre las muertes violentas
en el seno de la pareja eso son las
cifras de la gendarmería de la policía
que son públicas porque las asociaciones
han reclamado solamente desde 2000 2006
en francia y efectivamente desde hace ya
varios años se ve que hay una
estabilidad una mujer muere cada dos
días y medio cada tres días en francia
desde hace muchos años y por supuesto
para para retomar también lo que decía
paola es verdad que son mujeres que en
su mayoría han denunciado en antemano
que había violencia es decir que el 75%
de las mujeres que han
35 por ciento de las mujeres que han
muerto ya habían
advirtieron de cierta manera de las que
advirtieron
75% habían hecho una denuncia
y de entre los agresores solamente dos
tenían medidas jurídicas y de las cuales
una sola tenía una ordenanza de
protección es decir que las mujeres
hablan las mujeres piden ayuda las
asociaciones están muy al corriente de
lo que son las medidas de peligrosidad
para analizar las situaciones y ver que
no es lo mismo un agresor que tiene
antecedentes penales que no respeta
ninguna medida que tiene adicciones que
es violento hacia los niños que ha sido
violencia muy grave o violencia sexual
son criterios de peligrosidad que se ven
que se pueden participar y que se pueden
actuar o sea que hay un gran
disfuncionamiento dijéramos exactamente
este es un problema no solo
administrativo evidentemente pero de
gestión de lo que son las situaciones de
crisis o de urgencia en las que se
pueden enfrentar una mujer que tiene en
peligro su vida simple y sencillamente a
este propósito
maria jose estamos hablando de
feminicidio pero la cosa que me
sorprende es porque francia ha tardado
tanto tiempo en integrar incluso en sus
diccionarios
feminicidio yo me encontré con el hecho
de que el petirrojo vera que es un
diccionario de referencia es el
diccionario de referencia aquí en
francia solo íntegro de esa palabra en
el 2015 que explica este retraso cuando
se le compara con otros países claro
gravable o sea lo que sí es cierto es
que el término feminicidio ya está
dentro del debate público gracias
justamente de las movilizaciones masivas
de pues de movimientos feministas para
justamente introducir este término
dentro de la agenda pública como
mencionas lo que aún no se ha logrado es
justamente que el fenicio sea un
concepto jurídico que esté dentro del el
derecho francés y hasta el año pasado
aún estaba en debate para la reforma del
código civil y que justamente el fin
inicio sea parte de el código civil como
como un término y bueno como te decía
justamente aprovechando las elecciones
esta puede ser de nuevo una oportunidad
para los minutos feministas para por
ejemplo hacer esa demanda que el
feminicidio forma parte del nuevo
ordenamiento jurídico francés ya vamos
avanzando como quiera
es el 4 trazo pero se van avanzando en
la situación esta es la cosa bien hay
que señalar una cuestión de manuel ma
con ha impulsado una serie de reformas a
lo largo de su mandato de estos primeros
cinco años ya se confirma que se
presenta como candidato a la presidencia
de la república ha impulsado cuatro
grandes leyes al respecto dos que llaman
la atención en el 2018 aprobó una ley
que prolongaba de 20 a 30 años la
prescripción para los crímenes de
sexuales contra menores notablemente en
el 2019 también aprobó una ley sobre la
violencia en el seno de la familia sin
duda alguna son pasos importantes que se
están dando pero de este tema vamos a
hablar en unos instantes más porque
tenemos una pequeña pausa en breves
instantes volvemos cuando sólo con
ustedes estamos aquí en primera plana
en la cee del cono sur a norte américa
de los andes a centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
por qué de bienvenidos a la noticia de
france
telecom
maria sicav
y casi 99 millones de ustedes nos siguen
cada semana en france 24
chocrón taxis o conference means como
chivas
muchas gracias
pekín
liberté égalité actual y t
estamos de regreso aquí en primera plana
en compañía de nuestras invitadas y
especialistas en el tema de la violencia
contra las mujeres maría eugenia uriburu
o maría josé zorrilla y paola martínez
yo destacaba hace unos instantes paola
las medidas que ha tomado el gobierno de
manuel macro que balance se puede hacer
de esas cuatro grandes leyes que se han
impulsado a lo largo de su mandato yo
soy la pesimista de turno lo siento pero
si bien porque yo consideré que el tema
en el tema que tratar de manera bastante
seria si bien es cierto el marco teórico
el marco legal favorece es justamente
que las costas sean tomadas en serio y
díaz ese marco legal más bien en el caso
de francés tiene una relación de
causa-efecto el año pasado por ejemplo
hubo un atroz crimen de chain es una
joven de 31 años madre de tres hijos que
fue asesinada brutalmente por su marido
y ahí se recuerdan de nuevo que hay que
activar las políticas y lanzan una serie
de baterías nuevamente de medidas que
van a acompañar lo que tú mencionadas
anteriormente qué pasa con esas medidas
que insisto que son medidas que son más
bien para a acompañar lo que ya sucede
un poco de aceptar el mal que está
presente más bien como una medida de
prevención que cambió después el
asesinato de chain es cuando emanuel
macrón y el gobierno de un nuevo toma
seriamente el caso que lo que tú
mencionadas anteriormente coordina
dispositivos para incrementar la
eficacia de las asociaciones las
asociaciones son las que más trabajan al
respecto el problema o naya en trabas es
la parte judicial lo que tú mencionas
anteriormente en la tipificación del
delito definición no está incorporado
del código penal francés entonces eso
hay que cambiarlo o que la ley está bien
acompaña a ciertas cosas pero que
cambiar esa parte segundo elemento la
justicia tarda un montón en que esas
denuncias sean efectiva y que pueda
haber un seguimiento para el agresor las
penas son bastante bajas los hombres
sienten estando cerca de las mujeres
recién se incorpora el brazalete de
alejamiento hacia las mujeres entonces
si bien es cierto esas medidas han sido
lanzadas como yo decía anteriormente y
lo mencionábamos como el faro el pilar
del gobierno d el macro cada vez que hay
un caso que hace un choque la opinión
pública
se acuerda del fenómeno y lanza una
nueva batería siendo que el proceso son
procesos largos y paulatinos que se
deben acompañar todo el tiempo la
interrumpo porque yo estoy de acuerdo
con usted pero no se puede negar que en
estos pasados cinco años se han
impulsado cuatro leyes que incluso las
organizaciones feministas dicen son
buenas no es suficiente pero son buenas
ahora me permite derivar hace un punto
porque es españa' citado siempre como un
gran ejemplo en europa
entonces simplemente hay una cifra que
hay que mantener en la cabeza o sobre
tener que es que españa registra dos
veces menos de asesinatos de feminicidio
que en francia que es lo que explica
este dispositivo que lo que ha hecho que
los dispositivos españoles hagan que la
violencia y los asesinatos de mujeres
bajen si simplemente no que desaparezcan
pero por lo menos han bajado
considerable destaca un fenómeno que es
el tiempo en españa fueron pioneras en
este en este aspecto en el 2004 se hizo
la primera ley integral de protección
contra las violencias hacia la
estamos hablando de hace 17 17 años
francia lo incorpora hace cinco años
atrás es ese gran la gran diferencia
segundo en españa también existe lo que
se llama el juzgado de violencia sobre
la mujer que acelera efectivamente los
procesos y ahí es donde francia tiene un
problema los jueces por ejemplo
los jueces que instruyen los casos de
violencia de género en francia se forman
tres horas contra ocho meses de un juez
español hay una gran diferencia de como
formamos las personas que van a acoger
esa acción esas denuncias por ejemplo
para que las cosas sean efectiva y que
las penas y las penas sean aplicadas y
es verdad lo que lo que mencionaba
durante estos tres últimos años todos
los feminicidios en francés en españa
han ido bajando no por tanto la
violencia machista ha bajado y eso hay
que considerarlo como yo no porque lo
importante es la definición de mí
exactamente en qué humor el femicidio
como lo decía es la punta de la jce
verde las violencias sistemáticas y
continuas que viven las mujeres en
europa entera no solamente en francia y
en españa sino que en toda europa
entonces está en eso en el tiempo y es
ahora y sobre todo en cómo damos
disposiciones como favorecemos y de
centrábamos mecanismos judiciales para
que estas denuncias sean tratadas y sean
penalizadas después
hablábamos precisamente con la
comparación con el caso español hay un
elemento que es fundamental en esto que
es el famoso brazalete de distancia ción
que se le llama no en españa lo han
puesto en práctica desde hace bastante
tiempo aquí en francia empieza a
utilizarse pero apenas se generalizó el
año pasado
concretamente que representa este
brazalete que tanto ayuda a prevenir
justamente que se reproduzcan estos
casos de violencia o asesinatos de
mujeres el brazalete como todos los
otros dispositivos que puedan proteger a
la mujer pero que digamos el brazalete
está en el hombre hasta ahora estaban
siempre el teléfono guardan re grave
peligro es la mujer el que lo tiene
más de dos mil teléfonos de este tipo
que no todos están distribuidos que
estén
exactamente
perdone que son activos exactamente son
son pocos pero hay cada vez más así como
hay cada vez más ordenanzas de
protección que son las que permiten que
haya varias medidas no solamente algo
aislado lo positivo el brazalete es que
efectivamente esto está en el agresor ya
no solamente la víctima la que va a
estar teniendo que protegerse ella sola
sino que además es el agresor el que
está penalizado con este brazalete en
ese sentido es muy positivo luego
todavía muy pronto para tener una
evaluación de la eficacidad
[Música]
eficacidad de
eficacia perdón muchas gracias de este
dispositivo
porque como ya le digo la desde el 2010
tenemos la ordenanza de protección como
la ley en francia y realmente hace muy
poco que se ha podido meter en digamos
tener en práctica este tipo de
protocolos que son los que protegen
globalmente la violencia hacia las
mujeres es un problema muy complejo no
se pueden atacar solamente con un
ministerio o con una con una medida
judicial tiene que ser realmente social
económica de seguridad de justicia
psicológica de salud es decir todos los
actores tienen que tener una formación
maria jose a este propósito utilizando
los mecanismos de prevención que puede
haber contra la violencia hacia las
mujeres de acuerdo con las cifras
oficiales del gobierno del presidente de
manuel macrón durante su mandato se han
creado más de 2700 lugares para que las
mujeres que puedan ser agredidas se
protejan según las propias cifras esto
representa un 30 por ciento
aproximadamente de incremento con
respecto a lo que estaba a los lugares
que existían antes de que llegara la
presidencia las organizaciones
feministas los colectivos de defensa de
los derechos de las mujeres dicen esto
no basta se requiere que haya tres
cuatro o cinco veces más cuál es el
criterio porque en dos seis o siete
veces más claro claro es que realmente
estos 2700 lugares creados por macro no
son suficientes es la verdad y como
señala la fundación de las mujeres han
pedido que se aumente la plaza de 3 a 5
veces pero además de eso han pedido que
se aumente el financiamiento de estas
plazas de 5 a 8 veces es decir
398 a 398 millones de euros a 663
millones de euros y que realmente para
nosotros puede parecer muchísimo de
dinero pero realmente solamente si
representa un 13 por ciento del
presupuesto estatal para la pública para
la política de habitación en el caso
español son más de mil millones si no
mal entiendo que se dedican precisamente
a defender los derechos de las mujeres
esto cantaría bastante en el caso
español
si en el caso español sí pero en el caso
francés pues todavía estamos bastante
lejos y por esa razón perdón justo para
agregar que las asociaciones feministas
piden a todos los candidatos ya mermaron
mil millones de euros para poder
avanzar en esa materia mil millones de
euros para empezar no es la cifra
simbólica es lo que se necesita
exactamente para poder continuar en este
en este sistema como bien lo mencionaba
de poder configurar todos los elementos
sociales prevención albergue
etcétera para que las mujeres sean
protegidas y poder erradicar finalmente
este este flagelo muy bien reitero
estamos a menos de 40 días de la
elección presidencial francesa hay
varios candidatos
próximamente vamos a conocer la lista
definitiva de los candidatos depende de
un tema administrativo pero yo quisiera
preguntarle a las tres han ustedes leído
los programas de los candidatos a la
presidencia en el tema de la mujer saben
ustedes lo que plantean unos y otros les
preguntaría por ejemplo por ejemplo
dentro de esta panoplia absoluta de
candidatos que existen los candidatos de
la izquierda son los que se destacan por
las políticas contra los feminicidios
principalmente yo lo que me lanzo que no
es su primera calidad
ahora sí sumisa él propone estos mil
millones de euros que los va a
desbloquear para que puedan ser
efectivos también él propone
bastante
cercano con las asociaciones para poder
establecer estas conexiones y estos
puentes que decían mis compañeras
anteriormente para poder trabajar tanto
desde la esfera de la sociedad civil y
también de la parte judicial después
está usted que es el candidato al
comunista también que también establece
y sobre todo también ha hablado de otro
elemento interesante que es
terminar con la cultura de la violación
que de alguna manera lo que yo decía
antes es decir cuando las mujeres van a
van a denunciar estos casos de que el
estereotipo de que porque estaba vestía
por algo el lema de las feministas
chilenas las tesis y la culpa no era mía
ni dónde estaban ni cómo vestía dio la
vuelta al mundo y hace con toda la
sociedad entonces él trata de quiere
también incrementar e incorporar hasta
terminar con la cultura de la violación
después tenemos anida algo que se
inspira el modelo español para poder
poder hacer esto y hay unos grandes
ausentes en estas políticas que son las
las derechas sin contar por supuesto al
candidato de la extrema derecha eric
tibusch que es el prototipo absoluto y
el símbolo de urna
de un machismo de una masculinidad
tóxica en la cual dice que es el mal
dominante
marilé personalmente quiere penalizar la
violencia de las calles y valérie
pécresse digamos de los 4 carlos derecho
esta acto de 24 páginas que tiene su
programa dedica tres líneas al tema de
la mujer entonces si bien estamos en una
coyuntura que está más centrado en el
tema ucraniano en el tema del poder de
compra y la inmigración yo siento y
presiento que el tema la feminización no
será un
elemento importante dentro de la campaña
presidencial nos queda por ver
evidentemente qué es lo que va a
plantear ahora ya el candidato manuel
macro como modificación como avance
seguramente habrá nuevas proposiciones
no tengo la menor duda yo quisiera
porque nos queda poco tiempo a planteles
algunas cuestiones muy concretas mar
ingenia recuerdo que usted es psicóloga
concretamente que se puede hacer en
materia de educación porque no sólo es
un problema de prevención general de
leyes pero también un problema de
educación de la sociedad
la educación para la igualdad de la que
las mujeres forman parte del género
humano que tienen tantos derechos como
los hombres
una vida sin violencia
por supuesto en la educación una
educación para la igualdad todos los
programas que puedan trabajar estas
cuestiones en todos los ámbitos como
decía es transversal el desde el
económico desde las empresas que se
tenga en cuenta también
estas estas problemáticas en todas las
entre otros segundos paula martínez que
se puede hacer usted como perdón para
bola como periodista disculpa que se
puede hacer en el medio de la
información precisamente en 30 segundos
para ayudar a combatir este tipo de no
se lo puede ver a esta habla hablo como
madre también y profesora de jóvenes y
estudiantes
hay que educar
hay que seguir si hay que seguir
visibilizando los casos hay que seguir
educando en la paridad enseñarle a los
jóvenes y a las niñas que no es normal
que un chico más de una chica que no es
normal que la chica se deje en violentar
educación educación y educación es la
única manera es la prevención aunque
para no después que eso es a la tristeza
se transforma en rabia
y maria jose como politóloga
precisamente donde hay que apretar más
en el sistema político para que ésta
evolucione mucho más rápido las medidas
preventivas 30 segundos diarios hay tres
ejes a desarrollar primero un mayor
financiamiento como ya hemos conversado
un mayor apoyo a las asociaciones y
necesitamos también la voluntad política
para cambiar las cosas pues hay quienes
de ustedes no hagamos ya llegamos al
final de esta en primera plana no me
queda más que agradecerle a mis
invitadas maría eugenia uriburu
psicóloga maría josé zorrilla politóloga
ya paola martínez periodista su
presencia a ustedes les damos una nueva
cita la próxima semana aquí en otra en
primera plana gracias por su presencia
ah